[Music]
in jealous coworker news see you jealous
of my boyhood dreams submitted by KFC
vs. Popeye biscuits 79 year old flight
attendant who shouldn't be doing that
anymore says she was fired because her
co-workers were jealous of her gaze
earnest editor you're [ __ ] well if
she's 79 and still working that's just
unfavorable is that how much seniority
she has well she got fired she wore to
life's time times she hasn't worked
license for 57 years
no she's 79 but she's worked for 57
business greens she started with the
propeller plane-- started with the
wright brothers do leather ear ear
must've she started with [ __ ]
Leonardo da Vinci with this bicycle
airplane er a contraption dude I wonder
what all that traveling does to
someone's body
oh look she hasn't called in sick for 30
or 40 or change that sure must met my
mom you do with so many people so maybe
your immune system gets built up by
being with so many international people
you know she get all the germs of the
world so the first few years like let me
knock this out I am good she might be a
petri dish just [ __ ] take her blood
sample and see how many kinds of
different diseases she has Wow like
earlier like immunity immunity no she
started she was been employed by Delta
since 1962
I like Delta yeah Lee does attender good
it's a long time that's a long as so we
made this job that's longer than my life
yeah
a lot longer than my dad life your desk
young yeah and more than 70 damn my mom
yeah he's been working longer than my
sister was born my goodness that's crazy
she's so old my sister she's working
[Laughter]
can't tell she's she's about to turn 80
never mind she doesn't dude that was a
[ __ ] different time looking that
doesn't look like she can handle
turbulence very well I think she's too
brittle
she's like hits a wall she had those
turbulence is the best yeah I know I've
been through worse [ __ ] looks like a
[ __ ] conductor
yeah what is he he's a trained pilot I
love those pictures you see I've no
desire they're like really retired
because I gotta do something
at least a little thing like that like a
big thing but I keep me library or
something like man something I bet you
being a flight attendant is just fun
though cuz you're traveling all over I
need to stay in those you always have to
keep hopping or do you like for a bay
like for an hour be like why you be here
oh you you have a hub so like you have
your belly so like oh she's stationed in
LA
yeah she's actually number one like
ranked the top in LA and she wants to
meet what four hundred thousand a year
250 thousand whoa what because every
year like personnel again
she gets first dibs on the most coveted
location but she gets to go to like all
the cool location right she's the queen
of the sky why did she get fired
awesome yeah like how they were jealous
of your Senora but she's number one he
was number one ranking flight attendant
in LA and ranked fifth she's in the
whole country
so she outlived all of them so that's
like how am I could join her on your
team and it's like the he just won his
fifth NBA championship next season rolls
around you're fired MJ yeah right why
what is she saying that every year they
had a banquet for the top 1% who had the
most letters from the customers and she
went to that three times she's probably
like the best Oh gives good service she
was nominated by the Chairman's Club and
she's had flight attendant of the
quarter a lot of people got to learn
from her though cuz where flight
attendants are [ __ ] meme
are they really I mean what if she
worked that Delta so she probably went
through a lot the Asian ones make you
feel like really the Japanese when I was
on wood they were awesome Asian ones
make me feel like I'm violating labor
laws that's how nice they are
yeah is this kind of like I don't know
man if you awkward like I'm not I'm not
royalty like don't give me this one
yeah am I gonna get exposed that like
because I brought like my chess with me
it's like the bat where they put the
trash in because I didn't wanna have to
like wait for them to come and I put it
there like oh my god like it's like took
it from me to like play-doh and I was
like I'm sorry but help you guys that
thing was on the way they just freaked
out because that means that they [ __ ]
up and they were intending to you got
fired because we saw that guy bring the
trash he took - I learned that in Japan
- because there's no trash cans around
sided to learn Gomi Gomi me stress so
that's what has something's like go me
and they're like okay and like take it
away from me thank you
go me she was only one
more than 2,600 flight attendants with
more than 40 years of seniority or 40 or
more years she's saying that she has
been accused of stealing milk and from
the plane like a carton of milk
she can't even digest milk she's still a
milk and that's what she got caught for
and they fired her you know I call
conspiracy they probably don't want to
pay her $250,000 that could be it so
she's saying she's claiming that there's
uh that her co-workers have done this
whole smear campaign against her which
made her like eventually get fired but
Delta ended up having their own
statement like the spokes for a
spokesperson said in determining the
appropriate action for miss Gomez
multiple people considered all of the
relevant factors and made the difficult
decision to terminate her employment
Delta firmly believed that its decision
to terminate miss Gomez Gomez that's her
last name was appropriate and entirely
lawful when a violation of a company
policy is identified or inappropriate
inappropriate conduct as reported Delta
conducts a thorough investigation to
determine the appropriate course of
action considering many factors
including the employees overall
performance record and length of service
decisions like this are not made lightly
or without a comprehensive review by
many so they're pretty much backing up
the reason why they fired her but as of
mallick she's planning on suing them so
she got fired eight months ago um but
now she's trying to sue them because
they accused her of sleeping of taking
chocolates I'm not doing a good job but
she has countless letters from her
passengers that be wrong straight
killing it um and so they also accused
her of not being able to arm or disarm
the doors but she's saying that everyone
goes through through training every year
and they have to pass that training or
else they don't fly so she is very
capable of doing her job so yeah she's
old lady conspiracy yeah they were they
were just like
too much this is way too [ __ ] much ya
figure and then they they averaged okay
like if we do a payout it might be
cheaper alright so let's see what the
difference is if she retires at that
rate that might be more expensive so it
could have been a it could have been
that because a lot of big companies do
that because they just care about bottom
line cost analysis Toyota did that [ __ ]
to my friend's family where they moved
from California to Texas and they were
given an offer to basically move with
the company and go to Texas and so a lot
of people took the buyout and they're
like nah core gonna stay in California
and the people that went they got [ __ ]
over because what ended up happening is
they'll keep them there for a minute
they move their whole family they live
there right and then they start hiring
locals and they start staffing with
brand new people cuz its way [ __ ]
cheaper once they're trained everybody
then they start letting go of the
seniors cuz you gotta think about like
how much money you're gonna be saving
right you have hundreds and even
thousands of employees and if they've
been with you for like 40-plus years
they're about to retire that pension
plan all these things that you gotta
[ __ ] do
oh man that's all that's really
expensive yeah it is sad but that's how
these big companies like they're very
impersonal it's a strategy yeah that's
true they don't see that people behind
they just have the numbers and moving
things around I know and then you have
your stockholders and everybody that's
kind of like all they care about is
bottom line so when a pub when a company
goes public and all that it becomes very
impersonal towards it it's just a month
numbers game like that got a uniform on
anymore
their own show you guys interview - cuz
she speaks so cute I can't hear her
voice she speaks the old English like
her voice is so like high-pitched and
cutesy
[Laughter]
I'm curious like how long this lawsuit
will drag on for the problem I mean
they'll probably just settle it actually
like I imagine right like that's
probably settle it out of court
and that might be cheaper they probably
factor that is then to let her retire
yeah keep her on and pay her quarter
million and then let her retire with
whatever she's got going 50 something
years 57 57 years yeah like her career
is about to be a senior oh yeah at that
point it ain't even about the money cuz
we're 80 years old what are you gonna do
with the $50,000 salary yeah at that
point I'm like if I if I got a million
left I don't give a [ __ ] well I mean
inflation on that but equivalent what do
i do at 79 give it to baby just play its
purpose she's 85 pounds yeah she's
saying they accused me of taking nine
serials I'm 85 pounds I don't eat a lot
what would I do with nine cereals and I
would never do it in the first she got
the money what's wrong with taking some
cereals and chocolate cereal it's like
you took a pencil from the office we got
a fire
that's like telling a waiter like you
[ __ ] ate some of the food yeah we saw
you take that fry up before Union yeah
they are also accusing her of putting
Bailey's Irish Cream in her coffee at
work but she says that she doesn't drink
uh she doesn't drink and avoids sugar
because they also claimed that she was
still at diet yeah do today boy family
yeah oh my god dig she got you and
everything
yeah but she is saying it's like her her
colleagues that are trying to like stage
these things around her because that
whole cereal packet thing they left it
next to a purse but that that wasn't
even her purse I've never even seen
cereal on a flight I've had cereal first
class if they serve breakfast yeah
breakfast on there but it's use it like
you know like a yeah
furs eggs you know they have options
oh you could either get cereal you could
get like a warm ulta meal and I had
cereal without milk no they're not a
planar cereal area depends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]